hi everyone its Johanna here today's
workout it's all about targeting the
most common problematic areas for us
ladies which is our legs bums
and tubs that's right this workout is
going to be very easy to follow
low-impact
but at the same time very effective in
burning the excess fat off and to tone
our lower body up I love this workout so
let's get the energy up and let's work
out together so once we've done you want
we are going straight into the workout
and we are starting off by working on
our legs the first workout is a
combination of white squats with narrow
squats okay and we will be doing 10 reps
on that leg and another 10 reps on the
right leg so let's start by working on
our left leg so just why squats point
down bring it in and never squat
remember when you're squatting always
push up with your heels
that's right kick so this workout is
really to work on your quads your
hamstrings and as it push up it's
working on your bum get that's it really
go as low as you can without hurting
your knees and push up with the hills
get you can keep your hands by your
waist if you want to take your time
push up that's it good let's go dumb
slowed up fuss four more down slow and
not fuss good take a white star narrow
so which one you think is hotter the
wife's gone all the nervous one last to
get do a good job
one more and we're changing
okay same thing really work on your
quads and your hands-free and your bunk
what and good job same thing keep going
this is just your first workout get try
to keep your back straight and lace up
right when you're doing the squats
because this will prevent you from
injuring a little back good never squat
why there you go narrow I'll be there
keep going so number two the back string
that's it back straight last three white
backs to it as much as you can suck it
to me in last two down and one more and
narrow good job still on our legs we're
moving on to our second workout which is
a combination of two lunges the first
lunge is your side lunge so jiggle by
step nice to the side this is to work
your inner thighs and curtsy lunge
crossover twist
I just curtsy imagine you're wearing a
skirt okay so do that ten on one side
and ten on the other side are we ready
let's go side lunge lunge it down and
curtsy there you go this is to work on
your advice and also your boots you pump
it we're doing college side okay doing
it crazy
there you go lunch and cross and twist
good crossing twist over there
causing twist
lunch you're nervous same thing lunches
you want to keep your body up right okay
twist remark doing very good lunch hello
cross and twist lunch as slow as you can
cross and twist as low as you can
good last two twists are you having fun
yet
last one and twist now the other side
ready I'm going to increase oh man let's
go lunch you should feel your right hand
nice working and twist okay lunch crazy
tight twist give lunch
and twist
ah I'm using my family tea and twist
good job
lunch really go as low as you can twist
launch your own advice
please remember don't rush the backyard
or really focus on your muscles working
twist it copy that
lunch twist for more lunch all the way
down twist lunch get twist three more
lunge twist the last two lunch give your
thighs and your bums working twist lunch
and please get so we've done two legs
workout now I want you to grab your mat
and we're going down on the mat to do
some fun workouts okay that's serious
but I will tell you Matt so please don't
easily fall face both arms both hands on
the floor okay make sure they are
shoulder-width apart and what we want to
do is go tEEN TOP have you seen a dog TV
ball yes that's what we're going to
imitate a pink dog so keep your legs 90
degrees and just open it with your bum
and cozy now don't watch this workout
instead really feel your body ripping
good so we'll be doing ten and after the
ten you will create a little bit of
variation can you squeeze and close your
back straight squeeze and close try to
look straight at this to keep your back
straight good
five more squeeze your bum good
that's four ah ah it's not easy to
please and yes a dog give plus three
squeeze last two and last one and now we
are doing the same thing but we're
extending a leg at the end just to give
you that extra squeeze so ready we will
be doing another ten let's go up and
externally good melted through your bum
working squeezes and these good up
squeeze it and this burger you're going
to keep your back straight and your ass
as during the workout
extend burning halfway there
extend last five extend good job that's
four
cause you've been really good today
let's get mastery up extend last to
extend if your barn burning because
that's a fat coin and one more let's go
up squeeze and let go again you still on
the same leg
what we're doing now is confirmed late
so same position what I wanted to do is
to kick up extend the leg squeeze and
people that powerful bomb working and
bring it in and lift it up push all the
way into the bad part of the bomb
working so same thing we're doing
tag when you bring the legs back try not
to rest early okay so let's go ten up
squeeze bring a little bit up squeeze
nice and controlled good there you go
your legs up what is squeeze your bum
keep it up ah good halfway that way you
should feel your heart burning right now
get or more and after this we will be
creating some variations that's two and
one more good now bring your legs 90
degrees and we will be doing ten pulses
in the same position and just pulse it
up small positive and if you get up good
job for this should feel a lot harder
five six
typically a string up and hold it and
bring it back here
good job and just shake it up with my
girls all right so now we're going to do
exactly the same thing on the other side
I'm ready I'm gonna turn over so very
simple start with a dog pain workout
raise the leg up and squeeze three do if
I'm working
don't rush the workout keep your legs 90
degrees three future am i doing a good
job
Oh kid five remember to keep your back
straight as much as you can
seven good eight good job
nine one more and we're kicking it all
the way back so up extend and bring it
up good up remember it's only ten so
this should be very simple to do three
good look straight ahead or nice I
control five so County beat one two
three four good let's go one two three
four good keep going two three four
three one two three four good too long
extend bring it back and close one more
extend bring it back and close good say
thanks to
and we're doing you miss I'm sweating
and you get sweaty peaceful so we ready
bring it in and extend all the way up
good so really nice and controlled back
part of your butt get up in at five
please squeezing six seven well eight
key video volume 9
one more and we're going to pulses
give it up and pass pass good three four
squeeze it five six three squeeze the
top seven squeeze at the top squeeze a
top last three two and last one hold it
squeeze it
pull it please and let it go and just
relax rule and now we're still working
on the mat when we will be working on
our ass so the first exercise is single
nita combined with w time so just to
point out the body by placing your hands
on the floor and the dip your legs up
crunch it in and ultimate okay
we'll be doing 10 on each side and drink
immediately in 2000 million tops
alright are you ready let's go next up
go single 3d nice and controlled
warm to get three google apps for crunch
it five six
seven eight nine ten
don't let's go one also we ate two three
four pooja five six seven holes there
eight nine and ten
Kate no we're moving on still on our
tummy don't think plan so get into a
plank plank position
okay remember to tighten your abs and
don't let your back arch this is when
your back options you don't want that
you want it to be tight and straight so
get into a plank position
and we're doing ten closing price plan
and what you want to do is to live your
body up into a mountain shape okay roll
it
Emily see nice and ctrl-click straight
line that's your ten to release it
remember do not drop your back at any
time
three three job
is it straight back relaxed arms for
really squeeze up at the top good
ready squeeze it fine
push it all good six
screw the ass job - very well
seven up release eight squeeze it up
slap me please last night please and tap
and please give job right so that's your
let's dance and tops right now not so
difficult isn't it I'm sweating but
guess what we're going to buy now we are
going to repeat the entire circuit again
so everybody first I'm going to model
you don't work out and so let's really
pump up the energy and let's do it
together so let's start with white
squats to knee good
remember 10 on each side and you can
bring the speed up slightly kick -
that's it doing well and work out these
two sets together for good
remember back straight type in a house
by the slowest can six I see that you're
still smelling
let's get seven get a it's going so with
it when you complete the entire work up
nine last month
Sam get ready to change let's go
straight into it one squat get Y squat
two one one three four
that's great five push on your views six
do your bar game seven three eight good
we're not going to stop we're going
straight into the next version 9 and
awesome tank ready
so it's slide lunch okay and curtsy good
head on each side yeah one and two three
give we do feel in advisory board for
advice and bump five
oops can't-see-'ems for the admin 657
twist 8 twist 9 doing the very variable
time so let's change the other stuff
your one twist your job to do this video
you'll appetizer from 3d job for trying
to keep your body straight please
so don't twist and time 5 on your
strengths facing front
6 2 is 7
keep going 8 + 2 9 and let's grab on
that as quick as we can 10 grab a mat so
on your knees and on your hands
let's go straight into top pin ah please
10 on each side good three four
spinning up slightly five six
good job seven preview for society
boundary eight nine and ten now let's
extend as picky one gift keep your back
straight two three squeeze right the top
good for squeeze right top five squeeze
six you know what you're doing
seven last three ah good hi I'm you're
sweating in last one tip yes
so what do we get into Phil is ready ah
so you should feel the back part of your
barking - in three external mic and
squeeze remember nice and control bring
it back and control don't let it drop
really control it off with a squeeze and
roll it up and control up four five one
two three four kick it back fifth last
three good two and one we're going
straight into costs ready up two three
four push it I use five six seven eight
small pulses nine ten okay change the
side straight into dolphin one to bring
you hug it up three four five and two
tone l67 squeeze eight remember nice and
control nine ten when we do we extend
one good job to really reach as far as
going to extend reach three good for
reach five all the way
come on six you're gonna like this at
the end seven good eight so money we get
home you won not sad
let me do it out Hewitt ready in push it
up squeeze it back part of the box to
next place three control for Casey
facing a stressful thing five six seven
zero eight juice nine ten straight pulse
is 90 degrees one horses go one two
three four squeeze I'm really pushing
six seven eight nine seven and oh good
job still on the mat now we're moving on
to single in time so support your upper
body ready go 1 2 conjugate nice and
controlled three jump four five six
seven eight nine ten
w tuck your 100 in two three four your
abs working four five six
good job seven eight nine and ten good
straight on to the door pink max last
workout on your forearm ready flanked by
strips pull it
let's come together
we crunch of X DX I really see you look
nice and smooth
good let's go to up as high as you can
squeeze your ass release three oh this
is silly so dude please or squeeze I see
your mouth yes I can get 5 sugar your
mom good 6 size your head release 7 oh
please
last 3/8 come on your overs at the end
of your workout line remember little
drop your back wall right now
don't cheat 10 squeeze squeeze
holy release and moly
relax
well done so guys that was a full 15
minutes legs buns and Tom's workout and
if you feel that you want to do more you
can go on and do the third set but that
workout should really work your legs
your arms and Tom's do it 3 to 4 times a
week if you can and give it 6 weeks
don't give up being consistent really
push yourself every time you do it
challenge yourself more and you will see
the difference don't forget to have a
good meal plan to go along with your
workout as well please do like this
video share this video to your
girlfriends and do subscribe to my
youtube channel for more fitness and
nutritional videos thanks
you